I want you to take a moment and picture
the place where you feel most alive the
place where you feel energized happiest
maybe in the zone take a moment to look
around your happy place
and notice what you see what you smell
what you hear for me my happy place is a
grassy field in New Hampshire riding my
horse Brutus the Sun is warm and the air
is fresh and I take a deep breath and
feel alert and energized but also
relaxed I've asked a lot of people about
their own happy places and what I found
is that people prefer all sorts of
different places some like it loud
others like it quiet some prefer to be
inside while others love to be
surrounded by nature but what I have
found is that no one's happy place looks
like this the traditional office today
I want to share with you how we can
build happier healthier more productive
spaces for people it's a concept that
I've described to many of you as
wellness real estate the truth is we
spend a lot of our time indoors
in fact as Americans we spend over 90
percent of our lives inside that means
that the built environment can have a
drastic impact on our health and
well-being as future business leaders I
want to provide you with the information
and tools you need to build better
organizations by understanding what
healthier spaces look and feel like in
an increasingly competitive market
there's never been a better time to
understand what truly impacts health and
productivity for the last five years
I've been working at companies that aim
to make buildings healthier the
opportunity for impact is massive as
health is the fastest-growing and
arguably most important market and real
estate is the world's largest asset
class most recently I've been working
with the well building standard which is
a building certification program that
aims to make
healthier through design operations and
also policies today I want to share with
you my favorite well concepts where I
see the greatest opportunity for impact
air and light let's start with air when
you think about poor air quality you
probably imagine people wearing
facemasks
walking around in smoggy environments
typically in developing cities or if you
were in California last year during the
fires you may picture yourself walking
outside and feeling the soot in the air
hit your nose and eyes but even if there
isn't smog and even if there aren't
fires
outdoor air quality can be fairly poor
and what's concerning is that indoor air
can actually be 2 to 5 times more
contaminant contaminated than outdoor
air and what's concerning about indoor
air is that many of the contaminants we
find inside are actually invisible in
2014 Harvard did a study that brought
this idea of healthy indoor air quality
and work together they did this by
studying common office workers doing
common office tasks and looked at how
they were responding in terms of crisis
response and decision making they showed
that by increasing the amount of fresh
air in a space and decreasing the amount
of contaminants in that space they could
improve outcomes by nearly 300 percent
how did they do this they started by
replacing furniture office supplies and
cleaning products with equivalent
products that didn't off gas as many
contaminants into the indoor environment
they also thought about how much fresh
air was coming through a space I'm sure
we can all picture ourselves sitting in
a stuffy conference room feeling
sleepier and sleepier or how many of you
can picture yourself in an airplane
waiting to take off feeling sleepy er
and even a little bit dizzy
both of these responses are a result of
too many people in a small space
breathing out carbon dioxide without
enough fresh oxygen coming through that
space luckily there's an easy solution
for this called demand controlled
ventilation
with demand controlled ventilation
sensors sit in a potentially densely
occupied room and as more people come
into that space and breathe out carbon
dioxide the building's mechanical system
automatically pushes more fresh air into
that space now there were all air
experts let's talk a little bit about
light with a show of hands how many of
you use night shift on your iPhone and
for those of you with your hands up keep
them up there how many of you know why
you use night shift on your iPhone all
right about half the room is an expert
already in this space perfect for those
of you with your hands up you know that
our eyes are for more than just seeing
our eyes or more specifically our optic
nerves are responsible for perceiving
the amount and color temperature of
light in any given space let's take a
step back in time to think about why
this is back to a time before
electricity when we relied on the Sun
for most of our life in the morning as
the Sun rose we saw bright white blue
tones of light telling our bodies to
wake up and be alert and in the
afternoon and evening as the Sun set we
saw warmer tones of light or golden
tones telling our bodies to relax and
start preparing for sleep this 24-hour
sleep-wake cycle is known as our
circadian rhythm and it determines many
of our bodily functions so what happens
when we disrupt that cycle for example
when we see bright white blue iPhone
light right before we go to sleep well
we're telling our bodies to wake up and
be alert instead of actually going to
sleep and we wonder why we have so many
sleep disorders and what happens when we
sit under the same office lighting all
day long well in the US and in many
cities across the world typical office
lighting is warm in color temperature so
it's actually telling us to prepare for
sleep all day long
luckily there are easy solutions for
this as well having access to natural
daylight can keep our circadian rhythms
in line and even we don't have access to
natural daylight we can think about the
design of our overhead lighting or even
add a task
to a workstation they can give us the
right amount in color temperature of
light throughout the day with this new
insight I want to take you to another
one of my happy places but first picture
my commute a bustling New York City
Street stepping off of a crowded subway
platform all of this busyness disappears
as I step in and out of the elevator
into day Lowe's headquarters my office
would always hits me first is the quiet
thanks to carefully designed acoustical
panels on the ceiling walls and floor
the space is nearly silent 15 active
green walls greet me when I walk in not
only adding greenery to the space but
they have special nodes on their roots
that are pulling contaminants out of the
indoor air my arrival has triggered the
lights to turn on right white blue
because it's morning but I know that
over the course of the day they'll fade
to a golden color temperature helping me
prepare for sleep I take a deep breath
of fresh air and I feel alert I smell a
little bit of nature thanks to the
wooden staircase that connects our two
floors I know the workday must begin but
it doesn't all seem so bad as I grab an
organic banana from the cafe and sit
down in my organ on eclis adjustable
chair
my mind is clear now you may be thinking
that we can't all work in an office like
Dale OHS but Dallas wasn't just designed
with its own employees in mind it was
designed as a demonstration space to
show people what it looks and feels like
to be in a space that was designed with
people in mind and other major players
like CBRE and even Microsoft are also
implementing wellness design you may
also be thinking that all of this seems
expensive but luckily it isn't more
expensive it's simply smarter design and
even where there are small increases in
cost there's a clear return on
investment the American Society of
interior designers did a study of their
own employees after moving to a
healthier space and found increases in
productivity of up to 16% as Future
Business Leaders we have the power to
make our employees healthier
we can build companies that are not only
more profitable but also better for our
people and while it's the right thing to
do it can also make us more competitive
we can benefit from increases in
productivity and improved attraction and
retention my hope is that someday our
buildings will actually make us better
than when we walked through that door
and maybe someday our offices will
remind us all a little more of our own
happy place thank you
[Applause]
[Music]